all right my friends i am so glad you
are with me today because we are going
to need a full week to unravel
and talk through this election the next
weeks months
years but the big news of course coming
over the weekend
multiple networks finally calling the
presidential election for joe biden
joe biden has defeated donald trump and
will be the 46th
president of the united states defeating
donald trump by roughly 4.5
million votes in the popular vote we're
still waiting on final numbers from some
states but as of now
290 to 214 in the electoral college
georgia expected to push that
to 306 electoral votes the same
number that donald trump had in 2016
which at the time
he and kellyanne conway and others
described as a
massive landslide victory and the world
with some
few exceptions has breathed a collective
sigh of relief
it took days for networks to get
comfortable enough with the margin
in pennsylvania and nevada to call the
election
but they did on saturday morning leading
to the spontaneous breakout of happy
people singing and dancing
in the streets quite literally all over
the world the communism didn't break out
the suburbs weren't destroyed toilets
still flushed
just once and worked well enough but
despite all of the things trump said
would happen that didn't happen
um mostly masks at the events that broke
out although some real concerns about
coronavirus and we're going we're going
to get to that
joe biden will become the 46th president
senator kamala harris now vice
president-elect
kamala harris will become the first
woman in the white house as president
or vice president in the history of the
united states
her husband will become the first ever
second gentleman
of the united states the first uh jewish
person
man or woman as spouse of a president or
vp
now despite this donald trump has not
yet conceded the election remember
concession is an irrelevant formality
it is legally irrelevant but concession
is what you would expect an adult to do
donald trump continues to tweet insists
that this was a stolen election
that there was fraud or as he says fraud
like a petulant child and there is no
telling how much longer he will keep
going he's even being reportedly
pressured
by rudy giuliani and others to heart
to start holding rallies again rallies
not about people voting for him but
rallies to build
pressure for i guess recounts we'll have
more about that
maybe tomorrow but just remember come
january 20th
2021 donald trump will no longer be
president but for
now he won't stop truly making a fool
out of himself
tweeting such gems as quote since when
does the lame
stream media call who our next president
will be
we have all learned a lot in the last
two weeks well remember
when they called it for him with far
fewer electoral votes not even 270
actually back in 2016
he gladly accepted it trump also
tweeting in all caps
the observers were not allowed into the
counting rooms i
won the election got 71 million
legal votes bad things happened which
our observers were not allowed to see
never happened before millions of
mail-in ballots were sent to people who
never asked for them
now that's not true there were
republican and democratic observers
everywhere this concept of
legal votes is a disgusting concept
something is either a vote
from a person or it is not trump also
tweeting
i won this election by a lot
why have trump and republicans accepted
the results from the house and senate
but not the presidential results
everything was on the same ballots my
friends
and almost poetic was the news that at
the time
networks called the election saturday
morning donald trump was golfing
now as far as trump's next two months he
might as well stay on the golf course
for all i care to be perfectly frank
multiple reports are that trump's inner
circle has been trying to figure out
who's going to go in and tell him to
concede reportedly his son-in-law jared
kushner
trying to get him to concede maybe
although contrasting reports
that kushner is saying start doing
rallies his wife reportedly at least for
now his wife
we we will see what happens with that
after the the uh presidency is over
melania trump reportedly also saying you
should concede
save some face but others like rudy
telling him do rallies
so the focus now shifts to the senate
there will be two runoff elections in
georgia
those will ultimately decide who
controls the senate for joe biden's
first two years
i will talk about that a little later
now let's understand
how good this is but also the limits
problems aren't solved because trump is
leaving
we will all be staying vigilant we will
all be keeping the biden harris
administration accountable
and we have to deal with the virus we
may not have the senate
but this is a major accomplishment it's
okay to hold two conflicting feelings
this is news worthy of rejoicing about
removing an incumbent president
is difficult when we talk about the
power of incumbency
it's not a talking point it's a real
thing and yet at the same time we still
have so many problems
that now the work begins and it will be
big work
there will also be plenty of time to
talk about the problems of the
democratic party because to be perfectly
clear
massive recession record gdp decline
explosive unemployment rate out of
control rent for closure
crisis abject failure in dealing with a
pandemic
and democrats barely got the presidency
it came down to
under 100 000 votes in three states you
could say it came down to under 50 000
votes in two states
it's unclear who will control the senate
so the democratic party
eked this out just barely and almost
blew it and we have to talk about that
as well
it's not just the democratic party
trumpism
has not been defeated trump got more
than 70 million votes and we will talk
about that
so this should feel like what it is a
great start
and this is how progress is made we are
all correct to feel a combination of
panic and despair
at 70 million people saying give me
another four years of trump
but this is when the work starts and
we'll be going through
all of it one of our sponsors today is
helix
sleep and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled
about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for
me you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within 100 days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video